[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
yann et elle a parfois on n'a que des
éléphanteaux victimes de braconnage
particulièrement brutale car
malheureusement les bébés sont souvent
témoin non seulement du meurtre de leur
mère mais aussi la voix se faire
massacrer et découpé pour cent à 12 je
crois que les éléphants sourient
c'est ce que je vois chez les petits
leurs expressions faciales change
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
pour 1h30 d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités tenue évidemment à bonne
distance et puis nos reporters une
émission évidemment une nouvelle fois
consacrée à la crise du coronavirus en
france et dans le monde
le gouvernement présentera d'ici quinze
jours le plan de l'après 11 mai date du
début du confinement france emmanuel
macron elle a annoncé hier soir devant
près de 37 millions de téléspectateurs
le 11 mai un objectif mais pas une
certitude tempère aujourd'hui le
ministre de l'intérieur à la france qui
passe le cap des 100 ce quinze mille
décès depuis le début de l'épidémie
le temps des mines qui continuent de
sévir sur la planète où l'on dénombre au
total plus de 120 mille morts mais
certains des pays les plus touchés
entrevoit une lueur d'espoir après
l'espagne hier c'est au tour de l'italie
de rouvrir certains commerces
aux etats unis premier pays au monde le
plus touché on songe également à
relancer l'économie le continent
africain pourrait lui devenir le
prochain foyer mondial de la pandémie
mais que l'économie mondiale elle
devrait se contracter de 3% cette année
selon le fmi
l'organisation qui parle désormais de
grands confinement pour évoquer cette
récession pire que la grande dépression
de 1929
en france le gouvernement a cave encore
ses prévisions économiques pour 2020
avec un recul de 8% du pib
le plan d'urgence puis est relevé à 24
milliards d'euros contre 20 milliards
précédemment
[Musique]
il
la france passe donc la barre des quinze
mille morts avec 541 nouveaux décès en
milieu hospitalier liés aux cordes à
virus dans les dernières 24 heures
annonce du directeur général de la santé
jérôme selle au mans il y à quelques
minutes
cependant bonne nouvelle le confinement
semble lui porter ses fruits puisque le
nombre de patients en réanimation est en
baisse pour le sixième jour consécutif
avec six mille sept cent trente
personnes soit 91 de moins que la veille
l'ensemble des cas confirmés en france
qui est bien un total national ce soir
200 3573 cas en ce qui concerne la
mortalité
d'abord la mortalité hospitalière 10100
29 décès sont à déplorer en milieu
hospitalier
depuis le 1er mars 82 % de ces décès ont
plus de 70 ans 19 décès sont survenus
outre-mer 10 en guadeloupe 6 en
martinique et 3 à mayotte
par ailleurs nous déplorons 5600 décès
survenus au sein des établissements
sociaux et médico sociaux depuis le
début de l'épidémie
le 1er mars est rattachée à l'infection
que vivent 19
l'essentiel de ces décès est observée en
ehpad 5470 et 130 décès sont survenus
dans les établissements médico-sociaux
et de son côté le premier ministre a
promis cet après-midi de présenter un
plan complet de déconfinement avant le
11 mai et largement écouté le président
de public il l'a dit hier clairement a
demandé au gouvernement de préparer un
plan complet de sortie un plan
d'ensemble
j'aurai l'occasion de le présenter quand
il sera prêt largement avant la date du
11 mai mais il doit être travaillé il
doit être aussi travaillé en
consultation avec beaucoup d'acteurs
pour être véritablement à la hauteur des
enjeux
mais pour revenir sur les chiffres avec
un bilan journalier de décès à la hausse
ces dernières 24 heures et mes
préconisations démène
elle macron nous sommes en direct avec
bertrand legrand médecins généralistes
bonsoir docteur le grand merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france un
plan de sortie confinement présenter
largement donc avant le 11 mai a dit le
premier ministre en tant que médecin
qu'est ce que vous en attendez alors on
attend un plan de déconfinement avec des
moyens qui nous permettent de le mettre
en oeuvre
donc à savoir à des masques en
suffisance
c'est quand même la base absolue avant
de avant toute chose et surtout
probablement une politique de tests qui
soit non pas à baser sur un ciblage mais
qu'il se soit fait en amont parce que
les caractéristiques techniques des
tests actuellement ne nécessitent des
faits en amont et non pas en aval de
l'examen clinique
alors effectivement vous parlez des
masques et des tests emmanuel macron en
a parlé lui aussi quand il a présenté
cette sortie de déconfinement 11 mai le
président évoqué un masque grand public
pour chaque français
concernant les tests ce sont des tests
qui serait destiné à des français qui
ont des symptômes à ne pas confondre
avec les tests de sérologie pour voir si
on a eu le virus est ce que c'est
suffisant pour le médecin que vous êtes
non pas du tout en fait c'est une erreur
de penser que des tests avec une
sensibilité à 0 60 % doivent être faits
sur une population à prévalence élevée
donc pour vous traduire ça classiquement
plus la population à un grand nombre de
malades donc à l'issue de l'examen
clinique du médecin on concentre les
malades et plus le nombre de faux
négatifs va augmenter et c'est ça qui
est inquiétant c'est que si on se fait
cette politique là avec le test que l'on
a on va libérer un grand nombre de
personnes qui sont porteurs et qui
seront les flow négatif alors que quand
vous faites ce même test avec la même
sensibilité sur une population dont la
prévalence est plus faible c'est à dire
avant l'examen clinique et donc au
hasard on va dire à ce moment là où vous
avez un rapport de
deux tests négatifs valides qui est
beaucoup plus important est fait pour ça
que c'est ça ne doit pas être utilisée
de cette manière là nous sommes en
infectiologie et non pas en recherche de
tumeurs ça n'a strictement rien à voir
alors pardonnez moi docteur mais tout
n'est pas clair pour moi sur ces faux
négatifs ça veut dire que quand on a des
symptômes qu'on vient vous voir pour
être testé ce n'est pas forcément le bon
moment le meilleur moment pour que ce
test soit cian
quand je vois un patient si je dis qu'il
a le qi de 19 je n'ai pas besoin d'avoir
ce test là pour l'affirmer puisque en
réalité mon examen clinique est
suffisant et si je le teste je risque
d'avoir surtout des faux négatifs et
très peu de vrais positif et donc du
coup c'est une c'est une erreur c'est à
dire que je vais libérer des gens qui
sont malades en leur faisant croire
qu'ils ne le sont pas à cause du test la
sensibilité et de 60% c'est à dire que
40 % des malades vont avoir un test
négatif
si jamais je le fais avant mon examen
clinique donc dans une population avec
une prévalence élevée j'aurai beaucoup
moins de faux négatifs et donc je
libérerait - et mon test négatif aura
plus de valeur
or en épidémiologie c'est le test
négatif qui compte et non pas le test
positif on n'a pas la même notion alors
le 11 mai effectivement réouverture
progressive des écoles déconfinement
partiels lui aussi à la lumière de ce
que vous nous dites ce que vous êtes
inquiet comment va-t-on s'en sortir à ce
que vous vous craignez une une deuxième
vague
la deuxième vague peut arriver
évidemment c'est ce que tout le monde
craint on ne pourra dès confiné que si
on a la capacité au niveau national de
produire des masques pour l'ensemble des
français parce que le premier
déconfinement c'est le masque et le
deuxième confinement c'est de confiner
les personnes étiquetées comme positif
au hasard par un test ou étiquetés comme
positif par le médecin et mais à partir
du moment où on n'a pas ces tests
sérologiques comment va-t-on savoir qui
est immunisée
ou pas au virus est ce qu'on compte
finalement le gouvernement compte-t-il
sur une forme on en parle souvent
d'immunité collective ça veut dire que
voilà des gens vont attraper le virus
mais les hôpitaux pourront les
accueillir seront en capacité de le
faire
l'immunité collective c'est un doux
mythe puisque on est parti sur un sur un
début d immunité collective à 50% que
maintenant on est déjà plutôt à 60% en
vue de la contagiosité du virus et qu'on
s'aperçoit que dans les zones de
clusters on n'a que 15 % de gens qui ont
été immunisés ce qui veut bien dire que
soit l'immunité n'est pas ce qu'on sait
quand et donc pas durable ou pas
suffisantes soient très peu de personnes
ont été atteintes et à montréal virus
est très virulent ce qui serait très
surprenant donc clairement faire le pari
l'immunité collective c'est faire un
pari au minimum à 5 fois le nombre de
morts que nous avons et s'était fait et
c'est un pari qui est basée sur quelque
chose de totalement incertain d'entendre
des certitudes scientifiques le fait que
les enfants retournent à l'école est ce
que ça vous inquiète on nous a toujours
présenté les enfants comme des grands
vecteurs de la maladie vous étiez étonné
par cette annonce hier soir alors on a
certaines personnes ont annoncé les
enfants comme vecteur de la mède il mais
je vous rappelle que la plupart des
enfants sont possibles un automatique
c'est direct peu de symptômes et que les
études qui ont été faites sur les
enfants ont montré que les enfoncer
crête peu de virus donc c'est bien la
multiplicité des contacts cocon les
enfants entre eux qui guide cette
idéologie mais c'est pas une idéologie
qui était prouvée scientifiquement
dans le cadre du que vide donc non moi
ça m'inquiète qu'à moitié mais on n'a
pas de vraie réponse
aucun mot hier sur le traitement la
chloroquine gens parlent évidemment
parce que ça vous le savez suscité une
forme de polémique certains notamment
chez les républicains sont étonnés qu on
la teste pas le systématiquement ça vous
a étonné vous bosque est étonnant c'est
de se rendre trois heures à marseille
avec le professeur raoul depuis de ne
pas en parler
cinq jours après
ou trois jours après je suis exactement
combien de jours le temps finit tard de
passer beaucoup plus vite que la normale
donc c'est politiquement je n'ai pas de
jugement politique sur la sur la
question alors autre point qui a abordé
le président c'était une des grandes
inquiétudes des médecins actuellement
les patients atteints de maladies
chroniques et d'autres maladies
d'ailleurs ont déserté les cabinets est
ce qu'il ya un beau progrès sur ce point
les appels à la prudence ont été
entendus alors je vous disais la
dernière fois qu'on s'est vu que moi
dans mon cabinet je n'avais que le à peu
près 80% de mes patients qui venaient au
cabinet ce qui était nettement plus que
la normale je continue sur ce rythme là
aujourd'hui
avec ma femme nous avons vu plus de 80
patients avec 30% de personnes qui sont
en cause et qui sont que vide donc je
moi j'en ai pas le sentiment mais je
sais qu'en france effectivement beaucoup
de médecins
enfin on une souffre d'une baisse
d'activité ce qui est paradoxal et je
pense qu'il faut juste se rendre
disponible est allé répondre plus
facilement au téléphone que on a en
avait l'habitude avant merci beaucoup
docteur le grand médecin généraliste à
tourcoing merci d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france est parmi les
annonces qui était très attendu dont
convient d'en parler celle du retour à
l'école ce sera finalement à priori le
11 mai un retour qui se fera de façon
progressive précise le chef de l'état ce
matin jean michel blanquer a indiqué lui
que l'école ne sera pas on ne sera pas
obligatoire le 11 mai qu'il y aurait des
aménagements les précisions de rania
berrada les spéculations allaient bon
train sur une possible reprise de
l'école en septembre
finalement il n'en sera rien à partir du
11 mai nous rouvrirons progressivement
les crèches les écoles les collèges et
les lycées
c'est pour moi une priorité car la
situation actuelle creuse des inégalités
trop d'enfants notamment dans les
quartiers populaires dans nos campagnes
sont privés d'école sans avoir accès au
numérique et ne peuvent être aidés de la
même manière par les parents ce mardi
c'était au tour du ministre de
l'éducation nationale
appuyez sur cette notion de retour
progressif à l'école jean michel
blanquer re promet que chaque élève
bénéficiera d'un suivi personnalisé
il faudra nettoyer les établissements
élaborer tout le travail pédagogique
avec les professeurs il y aura un
accompagnement personnalisé pour chaque
élève
tout ne va pas se passer du jour au
lendemain nous avons deux semaines pour
préparer tout cela l'objectif c'est
contre le 11 mai et le 4 juillet nous
ayons réussi c'est trop socialisation
qui permettent de se remettre dans
l'apprentissage
pour l'instant les contours de ce retour
progressif à l'école reste très flou et
plusieurs questions se posent
l'état sera-t-il en mesure de fournir
des masques à 10 millions d'élèves les
règles de distanciation sociales seront
elles respectées au sein des
établissements scolaires
les collectivités territoriales seront
elles en mesure de nettoyer toutes les
écoles autant d'interrogations qui ne
rassure pas vraiment les français
certains d'entre eux approuvent
néanmoins ces décisions si toutes les
mesures sont prises pourquoi pas mais je
pense qu'il va falloir vraiment aménagé
de façon à ce que toutes les précautions
sanitaires soient prises les enfants
sont des porteurs qui peuvent être 100
donc ils peuvent ramener le corps aux
nazis russes à leurs proches
eux ils ne leur ont pas mais leurs
proches l'auront donc je pense que c'est
un petit peu trop tour et pourquoi les
universités ne peuvent pas reprendre
alors que les écoles primaires oui ça
devrait peut-être plus inverse
l'économie a besoin de redémarrer
également un et donc on va sortir quand
même d'une période économique qui va
être faire on va rentrer plus tôt dans
une période économique iw être
dramatique pour les gens et pour les
entreprises
et voilà il est obligé de relancer d'une
manière ou d'une autre l'économie pour
ça que les gens retournent travailler
pour retourner travailler faut que les
gens mettent leurs enfants quelque part
dans son allocution emmanuel macron a
précisé qu'en ce qui concerne les
étudiants de l'enseignement supérieur
les cours ne reprendrait pas
physiquement jusqu'à l'été ils se
poursuivront donc à distance les
modalités des examens et des concours
reste elle à déterminer et pour en
parler nous sommes avec benjamin a marre
professeur d'histoire porte parole de
l'ars cgt
val de marne bonsoir benjamin merci
d'être avec nous en direct suez et
france
quelle est la réaction j'imagine vous
avez parler échanger avec vos collègues
au moins par téléphone aujourd'hui
quelle est la réaction des enseignants à
ces annonces des manuels macro avec on
le rappelle un possible retour à l'école
à partir du 11 mai bah écoutez la
réaction est unanime c'est une réaction
de scandale mais de qui se moque t-on
enfin soyons sérieux deux secondes on
est en train de nous dire à juste titre
qu'il faut se confiner depuis des
semaines
parce que le govic 19 nous entoure est
comment dire pèsent au dessus de nous de
nos têtes comme une épée de damoclès et
là on nous explique que dans quoi trois
semaines il va falloir retourner en
cours à 35 mois je ma classe de
terminale l et à 35 à 35 dans trente
mètres carrés en masque sans avoir testé
massivement puisque emmanuel macron nous
a expliqué que les tests s'étaient pour
ceux qui avaient des symptômes
donc les porteurs asymptomatiques les
porteurs sains qui sont très nombreux
parmi les jeunes n'auront pas été testés
et donc on va se retrouver ainsi
confinés dans un espace très réduit mais
qu'est ce que c'est que ça pardonnez-moi
mais l'ordre emmanuel macron justement
n'a pas dit précisément vous allez vous
retrouver à 35 dans trente mètres carrés
il a parlé d' aménagement de protection
des professeurs avec des masques des
aménagements les allemands le fond elle
envisage comme ça avec peut-être des
petits groupes une violation de leur
travail c'est à cette habitude
madame excusez moi je suis enseignant et
l'éducation nationale en france c'est pa
pou de l'arb d'accord emmanuel macron
c'est pas de bol d'or
je connais un peu la réalité de
l'enseignement on va lui mettre où les
gens on va les mettre où les élèves on
va claquer des doigts et tout d'un coup
des salles de classes vont se créer
comment on va faire et les masques on
les attend depuis des mois dans trois
semaines y aura des millions de masques
pour 10 millions d'élèves et des
millions d'enseignants ma faim de qui se
moque t'on alors emmanuel macron je vous
dire il
le gouvernement a fait des annonces est
aujourd'hui gouvernement la main qui
tremble
on est en train de vous expliquer que
finalement ce sera progressif que
finalement ça ne sera pas obligatoire
donc on se fout du monde le gouvernement
fait des annonces parce qu'en réalité et
à le patronat derrière et que le
patronat met la pression pour que
l'activité économique reparte
et comme l'a dit l'une des personnes que
vous avez interviewé dans votre micro
trottoir eh bien il faut donc pour que
les gens de partir au boulot que les
enfants et les adolescents soient gardés
et donc on ouvre les écoles mais c'est
scandaleux cela alors rien la
chronologie c'est parti emmanuel macron
lui a présenté en tout cas un autre
argument l'argument social les
inégalités pour certains enfants c'est
très difficile difficile pardon
notamment dans les familles défavorisées
vous n'y croyez pas la bonne foi de cet
argument du président de la république
uniquement honnêtement madame très
sérieusement lorsque vous me posez la
question se donnaient pas la réponse
sincèrement est-ce que alors que depuis
des semaines on est en train de dire aux
gens vous suspendez votre vie sociale
parce que derrière il n'y a rien de plus
important que votre survie vous savez
moi j'ai été touché par la forme grave
du comité 19
j'ai passé quinze jours à l'hôpital du
chu de bicêtre dont onze au service
réanimation
cette maladie madame ça n'est pas une
grippette c'est une peste
c'est un fléau sortis des entrailles de
la terre et croyez moi il n'y a rien de
plus important que d'échapper à cela
l'argument de la socialisation ou de la
lutte contre les inégalités
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce fifrelin
qu'est ce que c'est que cette
tartufferie voilà donc écoutez moi je
suis enseignant lutter contre les
inégalités sociales
c'est la raison pour laquelle je suis
devenu enseignant là il ya une urgence
sauver la peau des gens tout simplement
et cette décision elle est scandaleuse
et il faut que la levée de boucliers
soit elle que le gouvernement qui est en
train d'avoir la main qui tremble cède
finalement et renonce
il n'y a pas d'autre solution cette
décision elle est scandaleuse
elle met en danger des millions de
personnels et elle ne peut pas
effectivement avoir lieu et se
concrétiser ce n'est pas possible
réouverture progressive des écoles savez
certaines écoles vont rouvrir pas
d'autres certaines classes pas d'autre
est ce qu'on crée vraiment une fille une
école à deux vitesses avec la macro ni
on sait comment ça se passe
tout n'est que rapport de force hier
cette annonce a été faite et encore une
fois la seule raison c'est la paix de la
pression du patronat vous allez le
patronat est à l'affût un monsieur route
des yeux est déjà en train d'expliquer à
qui veut bien l'entendre qu'il va
falloir renoncer aux 35 heures
donc il ya la pression du patronat et
monsieur macron peut bien prendre c'est
ton comm ca de père de la nation
en réalité la pression du patronat elle
est toujours là voilà pourquoi on nous
parle du 11 mai donc on sent bien le
gouvernement il sait que le jour d'après
va être très compliqué pour lui il sait
très bien que les politiques libérales
vont être dans le box des accusés
donc il sait il marche sur des oeufs
et il voit que cette décision elle passe
difficilement
quelle triste elle voit les premières
levée de boucliers et déjà il est donc
en train de dire non mais on calme le
jeu c'est pas obligatoire ce sera
progressif et bien écoutez il faut que
la pression elle monte pour que cette
décision soit purement et simplement
annulée
tant qu'on n'a pas la possibilité
d'avoir des millions de masques tant
qu'on n'a pas la possibilité de tester
massivement avec des tests sérologiques
on ne retourne pas à l'école voilà il de
la même manière je leur dis allez vous
allez vous mettre en grève vous
l'envisagez en tout cas dans votre
syndicat d'appeler à la grève
on envisage surtout alors il ya
plusieurs possibilités
on va discuter les instants ce
syndicales vont se réunir
y compris d'ailleurs je pense de manière
unitaire et en intersyndicale parce que
ce serait préférable mais je moi je suis
convaincu que le gouvernement rasent les
murs le gouvernement il sait très bien
que pour le moment on est confiné mais
que ça ne va pas être ça n'a pas à
rester éternellement comme cela est donc
le grand nord le gouvernement sait
pertinemment que il n'est pas dans une
position politique pour imposer le
rapport de force on le sait le
gouvernement a déjà largement renoncé à
pas mal de réformes extrêmement
tant du quinquennat on n'est plus du
tout dans le même logiciel politique et
emmanuel macron le sait pertinemment
donc encore une fois il faut faire
monter la pression
bakhit et savez même de manière confie
et on a la paix l'idée de faire du
gramscisme on a la possibilité d'impact
et idéologiquement l'opinion il faut
continuer cela et ensuite au moment du
décompte non on aura plein de modalités
d'action moi je suis très confiant il
faut mettre le gouvernement sous
pression et nous ferons reculer
merci benjamin amar professeur
d'histoire porte-parole de la cgt
val-de-marne merci d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt france et on continue
de parler de cette question des enfants
qui ne sont pas tous égaux en face au
confinement de ce retour éventuel à
l'école ou pas on en parle avec béatrice
copper-royer psychothérapeute
psychologue clinicienne bonsoir béatrice
copper-royer merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france on vient d'entendre
un professeur vous avez dû l'entendre
certainement en colère ça veut dire que
c'est pas encore gagné 1 ce retour à
l'école du 11 mai ça voudra dire quatre
semaines de confinement rajoutez à cela
quatre semaines au minimum si on a bien
compris quelles peuvent être les
conséquences chez les enfants la vie de
la psychologue et très moi je suis très
inquiète de la prolongation de ce
confinement qui est il est évidemment
nécessaire geslin il est il s'agit même
pas la langue
et si on met sur le plan psychologique
pour les enfants et pour les parents du
reste c'est quand même très très très
compliqué et c'est c'est important de
l'entendre aussi évidemment ce sont les
plus vulnérables qui sont les plus qui
seront les plus touchés
l'école et pour une espèce de soupape un
espace de respiration de surveillance
aussi certains s'y nourrissent à l'école
correctement hier c'était une évidence
que le l'absence d'école aujourd'hui
creuse les inégalités de façon
considérable et que les décisions de
remettre les gens au travail à l'école
ce sont quand même aussi prises sur des
considérations sociales
et ça me paraît intéressant de réfléchir
aussi les mêmes pour les plus favorisés
je dirais que moi j'entends au téléphone
puisque je téléconsult et puis je
réponds sur une plateforme
combien ça devient très long il ya
l'anxiété montrent le stress des parents
montrent les enfants deviennent plus
difficiles les plus grands sont un peu à
gérable sans arrêt vissés sur leurs
écrans les plus petits sans que le
stress des parents donc s'agite
c'est vrai que dans des zèbres des
appartements pas très grand c'est
compliqué alors on est à égalité il ya
des gens qui sont effectivement mieux
mieux logé que d'autres mais et puis
pour le le travail c'est compliqué parce
que t'es dit travailler avec des enfants
jeunes c'est très très très difficile
alors les couples quand ils sont
ensemble s'organise et même des couples
d'ailleurs séparé moi j'en ai entendu ce
se débrouille pour revivre ensemble un
moment pour que justement il ya un
relais auprès des enfants parce que des
enfants petits de 6 ans 7 ans il est où
et a fortiori les plus jeunes ils ont
beaucoup de mal à comprendre que leurs
parents sont présents à la maison ne
sont pas disponibles pour donc pour les
pour les parents c'est la quadrature du
cercle quoi justement quelles peuvent
être les conséquences sur cela on dit
toujours que les enfants aiment plutôt
être avec leurs parents pour une fois
ils les ont un petit peu pour eux mais
comme vous le disiez dans des conditions
un petit peu contrarié des conditions
difficiles comment les uns et les autres
peuvent ressortir de cette entre
guillemets épreuve
moi je pense que au début si vous voulez
il ya une espèce de réjouissance dans
beaucoup de familles les enfants étaient
très contente pas aller à l'école les
parents se disent tiens c'est une bonne
façon aussi de se rapprocher des enfants
mais sur le long terme
évidemment que on se rend compte que
c'est que c'est très difficilement
vivable
parce que les yaya là on est bien obligé
de continuer à travailler quand on peut
et que les enfants l'école et non
seulement à
lieu d'éducation mais entretient des
liens sociaux et c'est une grande partie
de leur vie donc finalement elle finit
aussi par leur manque et je crois qu'il
va y avoir une montée en puissance des
troubles anxieux pour ceux par exemple
par exemple pour les plus petits jeux
les petits vont peuvent penser par
exemple que l'extérieur c'est dangereux
et que quitter les parents ça va être
dangereux
donc on peut par exemple imaginer qu'il
va y avoir des troubles phobiques assez
important et puis pour ceux qui sont des
vins phobique par exemple les les
agoraphobes les agoraphobes les
phobiques scolaire par exemple c'est
vrai que repartir à l'école ça risque
aussi d'être douloureux pour eux
l'angoissé le monde quoi on dit sont
donc les les enfants s'adaptent plus
facilement que les adultes
quels conseils vous vous donneriez aux
uns et aux autres pour que ça se passe
le mieux possible vous parliez des
écrans effectivement c'est compliqué
quand on doit télétravail et qu'on doit
être prof en même temps c'est pas notre
métier on s'énerve parfois comment
justement éviter les écrans bref quels
sont les conseils ça sera ma dernière
question de la psychologue
je pense qu'il faut structurer le plus
possible les journées pour pas que ça
parte dans tous les sens et que plus
personne ne contrôle rien donc qui est
l'espèce d'emploi du temps fixé pas de
façon autoritaire mais en discutant pour
piller un temps d'abord que les enfants
se lèvent à d ores correct reste pas en
pyjama les plus grands enfin reste pas à
traîner notamment les ados qui ont du
mal à sortir de leur lit jusqu'à des pas
d'heure je pense qu'il faut structurer
quand même le temps ça c'est vraiment le
premier conseil que je pourrais donner
pas leur parler non plus de travail
toute la journée
là en plus pour la zone de paris c'est
les vacances mais pas leur parler
travail toute la journée mais identifiés
bien les moments où on travaille et les
moments où on se détendre essayer de
prévoir un peu attend à l'extérieur même
si les cours
mais quand même et puis pour les parents
qui travaillent se relayer c'est à dire
celui qui travaille travaille vraiment
et celui qui séduit les enfants ce que
des enfants vraiment à tour de rôle
merci béatrice copper royer il vous
reste en tout cas il leur reste les
téléconsultations avec vous sur internet
voilà si vraiment les familles crack en
tout cas merci à vous d'avoir été en
direct avec nous restez avec nous dans
quelques instants à 20h30 on parlera de
l'espagne toujours confiné mais où des
basques sont désormais distribués ou une
partie des salariés ont repris le chemin
du travail et puis direction les états
unis qui guette le pix donald trump
pouce au redémarrage de l'économie en
dépit des risques sanitaires
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici qu'on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit ce qu'on me vois pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
alors ce coup ci c'est interdit
d'interdire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci nous rejoindre toujours en direct
sur rt france il est 20h30 heure
française
cette deuxième partie d'émission
toujours consacré évidemment la crise du
coronavirus notamment dans le monde
l'europe qui passe le cap des 80 mille
décès liés aux kobe 19 dont plus de
18000 en espagne le pays qui lève d'un
cran son confinement avec un retour
partiel au travail dans les gares la
police et des volontaires ont distribué
hier 10 millions de masques pour les
employés essentiellement ceux de
l'industrie et de la construction
d'habitats khalifa avec à clément d'alco
lueur d'espoir la vie reprend timidement
ses droits dans cette gare madrilène et
pour ne prendre aucun nouveau risque la
police et des volontaires distribuent 10
millions de masques pour les employés
essentiellement ceux de l'industrie et
de la construction mayenne assez complet
ou mais cela fera un mois que le
gouvernement à adopter l'état d'urgence
et avec ce que nous avons vu ces
derniers jours
nous pouvons confirmer que nous
inversons la courbe j'insiste nous
inversons la cour nous avons atteint le
pic de l'épidémie il ya quelques jours
et les chiffres de cette semaine
confirme et que nous inversons bien
cette courbe citoyens qui ont pu
reprendre le travail l'ont fait avec à
son bord te ment que nous voulons saluer
et remercier les manches de sa carrière
après deux semaines d'hibernation cette
opération rassure les espagnols motivé à
l'idée de reprendre une activité
troisième pays le plus endeuillé au
monde depuis deux semaines seuls les
activités essentielles comme
l'alimentation la santé et l'énergie
étaient autorisés afin de donner un coup
de frein à la contagion
je pense que c'est très bien parce que
de cette façon nous évitons les
infections et c'est merveilleux que le
gouvernement fasse tu là parce qu'il ya
des gens qui peut-être ne vendent pas de
masque où ils sont très chers donc c'est
parfait
oui je pense que c'est la bonne décision
tant que nous le faisons avec ses
mesures de sécurité
distribution quotidienne de masques de
protection transports publics fluide
dans lesquelles les wagons ne sont pas
en
lee je suis venu ici en métro et c'était
plutôt bien avec une distance de
sécurité d'un mètre et 2 je pense qu'ils
l'ont bien fait l'économie s'est arrêté
pendant longtemps et je pense que de
cette façon cela peut revenir avec la
sécurité les 47 millions d'espagnols
reste tout de même soumis à un
confinement des plus strictes
seuls ceux qui ne peuvent pas travailler
de chez eux sont autorisés à reprendre
leurs activités
les autres ne peuvent sortir que pour
acheter à manger aller à la pharmacie ou
sortir brièvement leur chien les
autorités de santé estiment que le pic
de la crise a été dépassé depuis les
neuf cent soixante morts enregistré le 2
avril dernier
mais le président du gouvernement pedro
sanchez a prévenu la population
ils sont encore loin de la victoire et
du jour où ils pourront reprendre une
vie normale
et pour évoquer l'espagne qui sort dont
peu à peu la tête de l'eau qui distribue
des masques nous sommes en direct avec
le docteur philippe emmanueli médecins
français exerçant en espagne bonsoir
docteur merci à d'être avec tôt en
direct sur arte france l'espagne qui a
donc franchi la barre des 18 mille morts
recensés léger rebond par rapport à la
veille mais qui entame tout de même
c'est la bonne nouvelle un processus de
sortir léger mieux votre regard sur la
stratégie du gouvernement espagnol
beaucoup de morts mais en même temps on
pense aux déconfinement déjà ces risques
est ici chacun retient son souffle
c'est l'opération en quelque sorte
quitte ou double kit si les mesures
barrières qui sont appliqués à
l'occasion de ce retour aux activités
essentielles et non essentiels
fonctionnent double si jamais on assiste
à un rebond à la fois des contaminations
et des morts dans quinze jours c'est
vrai que ce retour confinement se fait
dans une certaine confusion parce que
les scientifiques ont réaffirmé leur
opposition
mais le gouvernement central n'avait pas
vraiment choix avec notamment
l'impossibilité d'indemniser tous les
chambarans temps et en alors parce que
il l'a bien annoncer seuls 3% des
salariés qui avaient été mis au chômage
partiel pourront être indemnisés
effectivement en temps et en heure si on
vous décrypte bien docteur emmanueli
le gouvernement espagnol a fait le choix
de l'économie au détriment peut-être de
la santé et peut-être d'une crise
sanitaire qui va s'amplifier en espagne
selon vous c'est vos craintes se sont
vos craintes
il faut dire que le fmi aujourd'hui
annoncé pour l'espagne une baisse de 8%
du pib dans ses nouvelles prévisions et
estimé que le chômage allait remonter à
20% avec une crise qui nourrit keane qui
n'auraient aucune aucune crise
comparable
lors du siècle dernier depuis 1929 et
c'est vrai qu'on sent bien que les
salariés qui n'ont plus de ressources
depuis un mois pouvait difficilement
peut-être attendre un mois
supplémentaire pour retrouver des
ressources vitales
elles ont néanmoins il ya quand même une
bonne nouvelle en espagne ces sept
livraisons massives de masques cette
distribution notamment pour les
personnes qui sont allés travailler dans
les industries
c'est rassurant quand même oui c'est
vrai que la population découvert ce
matin en prenant le chemin du travail
que effectivement les masques étaient
bien rares à l'entrée des métros et
effectivement c'est vraiment un
soulagement pour la population d'avoir
accès à ces masques sans devoir passer
par des chemins détournés parce que
effectivement le trafic de masse qui
s'ils existent comme partout et
aujourd'hui où il est masqué et est
disponible dans les principaux métro de
barcelone et madrid
alors quand on pense déconfinement pense
masque mais on pense aussi évidemment
test quid des tests en espagne est ce
que c'est la même situation qu'en france
on a du mal à tester les gens les tester
efficacement
alors on a toujours beaucoup de mal à
avoir accès aux tests
ils sont annoncés de façon massive pour
la semaine prochaine ils seront
réservées donc en priorité aux
professionnels de santé pour dépister
les professionnels de santé qui sont
éventuellement asymptomatique et
susceptibles de transmettre le virus est
également aux personnes qui sont
symptomatiques c'est-à-dire qu'ils
présentent des signes de l'infection
aujourd'hui ils sont annoncés de façon
massive pour la semaine prochaine
alors vous qui êtes français mais
exercer on l'a dit en espagne
quel regard vous portez sur la gestion
de la crise aussi bien en espagne qu'en
france on le rappelle à l'espagne qui a
payé qui payent un lourd tribut 18 mille
morts écoutez c'est difficile de jeter
un regard particulier sur sur la gestion
de cette crise parce que nous faisons
face à un évènement sans précédent et il
faut rappeler aux téléspectateurs que ce
n'est pas l'émergence non plus de
n'importe quel germe s'agit d'une
zoonose d'ailleurs d'une maladie animale
à transmission humaine et ces zoonoses
feront partie des maladies les plus mal
connu ce qui fait aujourd'hui la
difficulté de la gestion de ces crises
parce que on ne sait rien des
conséquences à long terme de ce virus
on ne sait rien aujourd'hui des
traitements potentiellement curatif
on ne sait rien de la probabilité
d'avoir un virus de voir pardon un
vaccin à court terme d'ici un an
alors ça le mérite de la clarté de la
franchise mais enfin c'est pas très
rassurant pour pour nous pour les
téléspectateurs qui nous écoutent ça
veut dire aujourd'hui que toutes les
pistes les traitements emmanuel macron
l'a rappelé en tout cas pour la france
tout on est vraiment au travail vous
vous n'avez pas vraiment d'espoir en ces
traitements on a beaucoup parlé de la
chloroquine notamment en france par
exemple
écoutez moi je crois que deux choses la
première chose c'est que l'accord qui
n'a été largement distribués dans les
hôpitaux en espagne ici les patients
nous avons eu cure été hospitalisé en
espagne rue de la chloroquine et le
moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que les
chiffres de mortalité en espagne ne
traduisent pas une différence
particulière par rapport aux autres pays
or la chloroquine a été utilisé et puis
la deuxième chose que je voudrais dire
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on a encore
beaucoup d'incertitudes et en fait on
s'efface en gros à trois scénarios le
premier scénario
c'est une épidémie qui s'épuiserait
d'elle-même peut-être par exemple parce
que ce virus serait sensible à la
température et que l'été permettrait de
terminer à cette grande vague de
pénétration du virus du corona virus
deuxième scénario c'est l'arrivée
effectivement d'un médicament ou d'un
vaccin
mais aujourd'hui on n'a absolument
aucune idée du terme dans lequel ça
pourrait effectivement arriver ça c'est
le deuxième scénario un médicament
arrive un vaccin arrive l'épidémie
arrêts
l'épidémie s'arrête et puis il ya ce
troisième scénario qu'on ne peut pas
exclure aujourd'hui qui est le fait que
la recherche ne permettent pas de
trouver un médicament à court terme ne
permettent pas de trouver un vaccin à
court terme et que ce qui se dit
aujourd'hui aussi par rapport à ce type
de virus c'est que les anticorps aurait
ignoré de protection relativement limité
on parle sûre en tout cas les autres
coronavirus qu'on connaît déjà d'une
protection des anticorps qui serait de 3
à 4 mois et dans ce scénario on se
retrouverait effectivement dans un
nouveau monde avec des cycles réinfectés
de virus des gens qui s'effectueraient
qui serait infecterait et à ce moment là
ça serait un bouleversement total dans
l'organisation des sociétés jusqu'à
l'arrivée d'un traitement ou d'un vaccin
il ce troisième scénario qui est
possible ne peut pas être exclu au jour
d'aujourd'hui
bon et bien merci docteur philippe
emmanueli médecins français exerçant en
espagne merci en tout cas d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france et
ailleurs dans le monde d'autres pays
parmi les plus touchés envisage aussi
une sortie de crise progressif et l'on
est un signe de l'italie où quelques
commerces comme les librairies ont été
autorisés à rouvrir ce matin dans
certaines régions le pays a franchi la
barre des 20000 morts mais il enregistre
une baisse du nombre de patients admis
en soins intensifs et ce pour le 10e
jour d'affilée
le confinement imposé depuis plus d'un
mois a été prolongé jusqu'au 3 mai
italie où 38 médecins cubains sont
arrivés hier dans la ville de turin ils
viennent prêter main forte au personnel
soignant piémontais le 23 mars dernier
une cinquantaine de médecins et
infirmiers venus de la vanne non
déjà rallié l'autre côté des alpes un
soutien évidemment très bien accueilli
par les soignants et les autorités
italiennes
c'est avec une très grande émotion que
nous accueillons ces médecins cubains
dans quelques heures ils seront déjà
insérés dans le système de santé du
piémont afin d'aider notre région à
faire face à ces dures batailles
il s'agit de la plus grande bataille
après la seconde guerre mondiale que
notre piémont que l'italie toute entière
a dû affronter
merci à cuba qui par ce geste renforce
cette amitié historique entre turin et
cuba et entre le piémont et cuba il y a
une valeur symbolique car le personnel
qui vient nous aider et nous leur sommes
reconnaissants se rendra à l'eau gr un
lieu où les trains étaient autrefois
réparer avant de devenir un lieu
touristique et qui accueille maintenant
des patients dans cette phase difficile
pour notre pays pour notre région est
aujourd'hui le premier ministre edouard
philippe cet entretien avec son
homologue russe survenue des discussions
la coopération et la solidarité entre la
france et la russie en cette période de
crise sanitaire pour en parler nous
retrouvons notre correspondant à moscou
antoine claireaux bonsoir antoine de
quelles informations vous disposez sur
cette rencontre
et bien les deux chefs de gouvernement
se sont usés au téléphone cet après midi
ils ont parlé de coopération de
coopération entre les ministères de la
santé des deux pays mais aussi dans le
cadre de la recherche médicale plus
spécifiquement les deux hommes ont
discuté de la possibilité que les
ministères russe et français de la santé
travaille je cite le communiqué
conjointement sur la recherche de
médicaments contre le coron minier
coronavirus et sur le développement de
nouvelles méthodes de traitement et le
test de nouveaux vaccins
ils ont échangé sur leurs retours
d'expériences respectives concernant des
mesures prises en russie et en france
pour lutter contre la propagation de la
pandémie mais aussi des mesures pour
soutenir l'économie
le premier ministre français a au
passage remercié son homologue russe
pour l'aide logistique au rapatriement
ressortissants français mais aussi pour
la coopération de la russie concernant
les vols de fret de matériel médical et
de médicaments qui transitent par le
territoire russe
et cela s'est terminé avec l'invitation
faite par mme ibrahimi chose qui
n'arrive voir filer à venir en russie
dès l'annulation dès la fin des
restrictions de voyages liés au corona
virus merci antoine claireaux en direct
de moscou et les etats-unis restent le
principal foyer de l'épidémie avec plus
de 25 mille morts et près de 600 3000
cas malgré cela donald trump continue de
pousser pour remettre le pays au travail
et relancer l'économie américaine
face à ce défi sanitaire sont pressés
dans la gestion du président américain
ressemble un condensé de sa politique
est un nationaliste de plus en plus
contestée par les gouverneurs david
khalifa le trump isma son apogée bornes
et vindicatif omniprésent impartiale
avec les voix discordantes donald trump
montre un visage radicale de sa manière
de conduire les affaires publiques
les tergiversations du président
américain face à cette crise sanitaire
sans précédent sont devenus monnaie
courante à washington nous parlons d'un
vaccin peut être un remède c'est
possible donc on verra ça mais nous
parlons d'un vaccin et ils avancent très
vite toutes les entreprises
pharmaceutiques avance très vite toute
personne qui a besoin d'un test peu en
ferrain ils sont tous prêts ils les ont
à disposition
en plus de cela ils en font des millions
d'autres au moment où nous parlons pas
de sitôt mais il me semble que si nous
faisons un très bon travail
nous maintiendrons le nombre de morts à
un niveau plus bas que si nous ne
faisons pas du bon travail mais les gens
parlent de juillet août quelque chose
comme ça nous pourrons sauver des vies
et plus vite nous pourrons remettre les
gens au travail à l'école et à la
normale une chronologie de déclarations
infondées qui a rendu plus que difficile
le travail de cet homme anthony fochi
conseiller médical de la maison blanche
depuis plus de 30 ans est expert
mondialement reconnue des maladies
infectieuses doit composer avec
la personnalité de donald trump à
plusieurs reprises il a dû en finesse
mais publiquement ont recadré le
président des états unis et rectifier le
tir après ses propos approximatifs ou
erronées je marche sur une ligne de
crête je dis les choses au président qui
n'a pas envie d'entendre
et j'ai déclaré publiquement des choses
différentes de ceux qui l'assurent
je ne veux pas le mettre dans l'embarras
ni jouer les durs je veux juste donner
les faits une rigueur qui ne fait
qu'accentuer l'amateurisme du président
au sujet de la science et qui ne date
pas d'hier
le washington post en janvier dernier
publie un décompte pour le moins
vertigineux au troisième anniversaire de
son arrivée au pouvoir donald trump
avait annoncé 16 1241 mensonge ou
affirmations erronées selon le journal
américain
il semblerait que le constat soit à
nouveau vérifié l'ambition politique de
donald trump semble parfois primer sur
les enjeux de cette crise sanitaire
d'où son impatience face à la mise à
l'arrêt du pays
j'ai eu de nombreuses discussions avec
mon équipe et des experts de renom et
nous sommes très près de finaliser un
plan d'ouverture de notre pays
avec un peu de chance même avant la date
prévue ce qui est très important
le gouvernement fédéral a un pouvoir
absolu il a le pouvoir
nous verrons si j'utiliserai ce pouvoir
imposer son autorité fédérale pour
ouvrir l'économie une volonté
significative de montrer qui tient les
rênes du pays
une autorité remise en cause par les
gouverneurs
ce sont eux qui ont ordonné le
confinement dans leur état et notre
président ce serait donc à eux de
décider de la réouverture est cette
passe d'armes pourrait également miné la
crédibilité du chef de l'état aux yeux
de l'amérique et indirectement menacé sa
réélection preuve en est 57% des
américains approuvent l'attitude des
gouverneurs face à la pandémie
seuls 38% ont la même opinion de la
réponse fédérale 1 pour revenir sur
cette pandémie
aux etats unis nous sommes en direct
depuis new york avec céline
hubert spécialiste des maladies
infectieuses c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir bonsoir célina
gombert merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france depuis new york on a vu
évidemment tous ces images terribles de
la ville américaine avec ses camions
frigorifiques en guise de morgue telle
est la situation sur place
je suis de peur à new york
et effectivement les hôpitaux sont
submergés cette semaine au cours des
derniers jours la situation était
meilleure mais comme vous avez pu le
voir à la télévision
nous avons des images d'un des hôpitaux
du queens un quartier où l'on trouve
beaucoup des grandes personnes qui n'ont
pas d'assurance santé car elle n'est pas
universel aux états unis beaucoup de
personnes également labaki travaille qui
ont des emplois qu'on qualifierait est
essentiel d emploi par exemple dans le
secteur du service des soins de la santé
et des transports dans les magasins ce
sont ces personnes qui tombent malades
et qui se retrouve à l'hôpital
ces personnes ton particulièrement
malades en raison de leur fragilité
c'est ce que nous vous nous expliquer ce
soir on avait mis d'ailleurs en exergue
le fait que les afro-américains été plus
touchés que les autres
plusieurs raisons à cela
par exemple il ya des raisons socio
économique c'est à dire que ils ont un
certain emplois qu'il ne leur a même pas
de faire du télétravail
ils sont donc plus vulnérables et sont
donc plus susceptibles d'être contaminés
n'ont pas d'autre solution que tel
travailler pour payer leur loyer et pour
nourrir leur famille
dans cette population il également moins
de personnes qui ont une couverture de
santé
il est donc très difficile pour ces
personnes
avoir accès aux soins de plus ces
populations on trouve beaucoup de
comorbidité telles que des maladies
cardiovasculaires le diabète ou des
maladies cardiaques
cela augmente encore le risque de
développer une forme sévère du
coronavirus alors à la lumière de ce que
vous vous dites une situation compliquée
et pourtant donald trump lui qui
aimerait bien qu'ils souhaiteraient même
si on verra qu'il n'a pas forcément le
pouvoir de le faire mais qui
souhaiteraient bien déconfinement dès le
1er mai faire repartir l'économie quelle
est votre réaction
deux médecins dans certaines régions
cela pourrait être possible mais il
faudrait beaucoup d'action au préalable
tout d'abord il faudrait que le nombre
de cas diminue que les hôpitaux et soit
en mesure de traiter correctement les
patients de plus nous devons pouvoir
tester les personnes qui ont des
symptômes
au moins si on la salle de la population
ou les personnes susceptibles d'avoir
été exposés
il faut également faire du contact
création si nous mettions en oeuvre les
moyens de traçage des contacts que la
chine alors nous aurions toujours de
milliers de personnes sont chargées en
saône et cela n'est pas du tout le cas
depuis la récession
nous avons perdu environ 25% de nos
effectifs publics et nous ne sommes
vraiment pas prêt à effectuer le travail
nécessaire à suite à la fin du
confinement
aujourd'hui céline aegon d'heures si je
vous comprends bien il vous manque la
même chose qu'en france des masques des
tests est effectivement une politique de
tracking qui est mise en place dans
certains pays comme la corée du sud qui
n'est pas mise également chez vous aux
états unis tout à fait je pense que les
équipements de protection personnelle
les masques de gants et cetera à ce
niveau là c'est s'est améliorée j'ai
effectivement un masque n95 mais on
s'attend à ce que j'utilise toute la
semaine d'être équipes ne sont encore en
situation de pénurie
et s'agissant de test il ne s'agit pas
que de cela il faut également avoir des
échantillonnages naseaux et sans avoir
mis en place de tels tests elle ne rend
pas les échantillons nécessaires pour
tester quelqu'un donc cela peut poser
des problèmes au niveau de la fin du
confinement
qu'en est il des écoles céline à grinder
parce qu'en france pour vous présenter
la situation sont fermés depuis un mois
elles vont le rester encore un mois
qu'elle est la politique aux etats-unis
sachant qu'on imagine c'est une question
qui est traitée différemment selon les
étapes puisque c'est son d etat fédéral
quelle est la situation par exemple à
new york sur le front des écoles il y à
des débats entre le gouverneur de l'état
de new york et le maire de la ville de
new york
on ne sait pas encore ce qu'il va
arriver comme en france nous sommes très
avancés dans l'année scolaire et ne
serait peut-être pas logique
aujourd'hui de réouvrir les écoles un
problème crucial c'est que beaucoup
d'enfants les enfants pauvres
recevez des repas gratuits à l'école
notamment par exemple à new york
cela a continué même après la fermeture
des écoles donc pour moi cela est vital
si la fermeture des écoles continue ses
repas devront continuer à être fournis
vous dites c'est vital
si la fermeture des écoles continuent le
médecin qu'en pense-t-il de la
réouverture des écoles en france
certains craignent que les enfants
soient très vecteur du coc vide 19 et le
transmettent évidemment à leurs parents
leurs aînés est ce que vous partagez
cette même inquiétude
effectivement je pense que c'est un
sujet de préoccupation même si les
enfants ne développe pas des formes
d'aussi graves de la maladie cela sans
doute effectivement peuvent-ils apporter
la maladie autour de même s'ils sont
asymptomatiques
si en tout cas cela ressemble à la
grippe donc la fermeture des écoles
semble effectivement avoir réduit la
transmission du coc vite un récent
sondage chez nous en france aif a pas
montré que seuls 38 % des français
faisait confiance à notre gouvernement
pour gérer cette crise du coronavirus
qu'on est il aux états unis est ce que
les américains font confiance à donald
trump qui on le sait a commis voilà
certaines intrus dans sa en tout cas a
pris un petit peu si vous me permettez
cette expression par dessus la jambe
cette épidémie due qu'aux vie de 19 au
départ les etats-unis sont très polarisé
les gens approuvent ou désapprouvent du
président enfin sur 1000 dollars
l'appartenance politique et et non pas
sur la base scientifique qui ce qui est
très problématique car nous devrions
justement nous fondée sur la science
pour déterminer nos opinions et non pas
nous fonder sur notre obédience
politique c'est ce qui est au coeur
justement des discussions autour de la
fin du confinement c'est plutôt
économique que scientifique
merci beaucoup c'est niang honneur
d'avoir été avec nous dans notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
restez avec nous donc quelques instants
à nous reviendrons évidemment sur cette
crise du coronavirus en france qui
franchit la barre des quinze mille décès
depuis le début de l'épidémie tous les
espoirs de l'est confinement sont
désormais tournés vers la date du 11 mai
en revanche pas de réouverture pour les
hôtels et restaurants à cette date
l'inquiétude monte
tout comme celles des économistes on
verra ça
[Musique]
l'écologie ce n'est pas de la politique
dernier rapport du giec sur les océans
comme ça fout les jetons
on est dans une espèce de déni collectif
on ne veut pas croire ce qu'on sait et
scientifique parle quand même de la
sixième extinction de la vie sur terre
sixième extinction et la vie sur terre
et à d'autres experts qui contestent
leur personne non non c'est pas vrai il
ya des climato sinon ce n'est pas rien à
part il ya des gens qui ne sont pas des
chercheurs qui parlent que la presse met
en avant parce que il faut que du débat
mais il ya plus de débat aujourd'hui il
ya plus aucun débat ce changement
climatique et on va vers un vrai bras
une catastrophe ou va vers une vraie
catastrophe et on a incapable d'en
prendre conscience
mais ce n'est pas de pessimisme nous
comprendre ce qui va arriver pour moi je
pense que les communes guerre
aujourd'hui on est entré en guerre
contre nos façons ville et les demis y
en a pas d 2000 ennemi c'est nous
il semble qu'il existe une architecture
naturel reposant sur le pli quel
avantage la nature aux rétais la
pratique et l'origami et comment
peut-elle produire des schémas de pliage
aussi complexe l'évolution a dû retenir
les systèmes de plis sommes heureux
parce que cela permet de développer de
très grandes surfaces à l'intérieur de
tout petits espaces ce n'est donc pas
surprenant de voir de l'origami dans les
ailes d'insectes et dans les feuilles
dans l'intestin
on peut même voir des système de pliage
semblables sur le cortex les objets
inspirés par les origamis surgissent
déjà dans notre quotidien
comment imaginer que le pliage d'une
simple surface plane
nous porte vers la découverte d'un code
universel de la nature
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici qu'on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit ce qu'on me vois pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire
nous allons évoquer ici les sujets
stratégiques pour notre pays et sur ces
dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous une
interprétation en france une quinzaine
de zones ont été sélectionnés dans les
années 90 par des militants dieu la
première erreur de notes administration
a été de croire que les terroristes
étaient des loups solitaires alors
qu'ils étaient la résultante de 15 ans
de travail de fond fait par les
analystes soyons clairs ils ont prêché
la guerre sainte et le problème c'est
qu'on les a trop longtemps les équipes
il ya eu un espèce de déni de réalité et
la famille drame du bataclan pour qu'il
y ait enfin une reconnaissance générale
de la situation dans notre pays
la ministre de la justice mme belloubet
annonce la sortie en 2020 de 43 du à 10
140 avant fin 2022 sur les 531 incarcéré
aujourd'hui
qui peut croire que la majeure partie
des individus mus par la haine de la
france est désormais libre ne sont pas
un défi pour la sécurité nationale
[Musique]
je serai votre sentiment sur les
mouvements concernant la manifestation
contre la retraite quand il ya autant de
travail qui a autant de chômeurs autant
de gens qui sont dans la logique comme
on dit aujourd'hui du burn out
qu'est-ce qu'il n'y aurait pas à
repenser le travail c'est vraiment une
question philosophique pour moi je
défends le gilet jaune qui sont pour moi
les sous prolétaires je défends
également ces gens là qui pour le coup
ce sont les prolétaires mais qui sont
organisés pour parce que c'est toujours
les mêmes qui payent les pots plus
modestes et c est pourquoi ce sont
toujours les mêmes qui échappent soit à
l'impôt soit aux ponctions d'autres
choses qui font que s'il y avait
vraiment un désir de d'équité les
français seraient probablement plus à
même de dire qu'il consente à ce
traitement est ce que vous avez compris
quelle était la revendication au moment
des gilets jaunes tout au départ ce sont
juste des gens qui disent si vous
augmentez le prix du carburant ne va pas
pouvoir des gens disaient mais moi je
suis chez mes parents parce que je ne
peux pas me payer un loyer alors que je
travaille donc dès le départ c'était une
revendication de dignité mais vous avez
dit on n'a pas écouté ces gens là
comment vouliez vous les écoutez puisque
personne ne prenait la parole et
personne n'était légitime pour
l'apprendre y en a un qui est légitime
pour prendre la parole sur ce sujet là
ça s'appelle un président de la
république parce qu'il est investi de la
souveraineté nationale
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindrons
directe ur rt france pour une demi heure
d'information il est 21h heure française
tout de suite voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce mardi 14 avril
le gouvernement présentera d'ici quinze
jours le plan de l'après 11 mai date du
début du confinement en france emmanuel
macron l'annoncé hier soir devant près
de 37 millions de téléspectateurs le 11
mai un objectif mais pas une certitude
tempère aujourd'hui le ministre de
l'intérieur la france qui passe le cap
des 15 mille décès depuis le début de
l'épidémie
l'économie mondiale devrait se
contracter de 3% cette année selon le
fmi l'organisation qui parle désormais
de grands confinement pour évoquer cette
récession pire que la grande dépression
de 1929
en france le gouvernement aggrave encore
ses prévisions économiques pour 2020
avec un recul de 8% du pib
le plan d'urgence est relevé à 24
milliards d'euros contre 20 milliards
précédemment
[Musique]
avant de se pencher sur les conséquences
économiques du virus un point sur la
situation en france notre pays qui passe
la barre des quinze mille morts avec 541
nouveaux décès en milieu hospitalier
dans les 24 dernières heures annonce du
directeur général de la santé jérôme
c'est long non en début de soirée le
confinement cependant semble porter ses
fruits puisque le nombre de patients en
réanimation est en baisse pour le
sixième jour consécutif avec six mille
sept cent trente personnes soit 91 de
moins que la veille
l'ensemble des cas confirmés en france
qui est bien ma totale national ce soir
200 3573 cas en ce qui concerne la
mortalité
d'abord la mortalité hospitalière 10100
29 décès sont à déplorer en milieu
hospitalier
depuis le 1er mars 82 % de ces décès ont
plus de 70 ans 19 décès sont survenus
outre-mer 10 en guadeloupe 6 en
martinique et 3 à mayotte
par ailleurs nous déplorons 5600 décès
survenus au sein des établissements
sociaux et médico sociaux depuis le
début de l'épidémie
le 1er mars est rattachée à l'infection
que vivent 19
l'essentiel de ces décès est observée en
ehpad 5470 et 130 décès sont survenus
dans les établissements médico-sociaux
traits de son côté le premier ministre a
promis cet après-midi de présenter un
plan complet de déconfinement avant le
11 mai le président public
il l'a dit hier clairement a demandé au
gouvernement de préparer un plan complet
de sortie un plan d'ensemble
j'aurai l'occasion de le présenter quand
il sera prêt largement avant la date du
11 mai mais il doit être travaillé il
doit être aussi travaillé en
consultation avec beaucoup d'acteurs
pour être véritablement à la hauteur des
enjeux et en france la prolongation du
confinement jusqu'au 11 mai prochain on
joue encore un peu plus dans la crise
cafés restaurants et hôtels
selon l'union des métiers des industries
de l'hôtellerie l'année 2020 est une
année de perdue pour les actifs du
milieu une véritable catastrophe
économique selon le syndicat qui salue
néanmoins le fait que le président de la
république laisse la porte ouverte du
site à des annulations total des charges
de restauration en raison des recettes
nul du secteur pour en parler nous
sommes avec un jean pierre pinelli vice
président du cercle des grandes maisons
corses bonsoir jean pierre pinelli
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
françois lors la corse qui on le
rappelle accueille chaque année quelques
3,5 millions de visiteurs soit 10 fois
cette population on imagine votre
inquiétude avez vous déjà une idée du
manque à gagner
grosso modo bonsoir d'abord grosso modo
si vous voulez on aura une saison qu'on
appelle blanche
mais on aura pas de saison en réalité
puisque le manque à gagner
mais le tourisme pèse 30 points du pib
plus des effets induits donc ça veut
dire que l'accord sera lourdement
impactés
qu'attendez vous aujourd'hui du
gouvernement on n'a pas entendu des
mesures très précises sur ce point des
manuels macron peut-être que vous avez
des informations complémentaires qui ont
pu vous rassurer sur la situation des
hôtels des restaurants
peut-être aussi des cafés will à
l'intervention de du ministre le maire
ce matin apporter plus de précisions
alors il manque qu à la marge quelques
petits a finement mais du moins il ya
quand même un effort de fait et surtout
dans cette crise il faut noter qu'il ya
eu quand même une une réaction très vive
de la part de l'état des du gouvernement
sur ce sujet alors une île dépendantes à
on vient de le dire au tourisme et aux
transports comment vous vous préférez
cette préparer pardon cette saison vous
avez annoncé comme saison blanche vous
avez monté je prends une cellule de
crise sur l'île de beauté tout à fait
mon tour du du préfet de région il ya
une cellule de crise qui s'organisent
afin de définir à la fois la spécificité
de l'île comme vous
de préciser il est surtout impacté par
le transport aérien il n'échappe à
personne que leur lit qu'elle est une la
plateforme essentielle qui dessert la
corse est fermé roissy n'est pour nous
quelques situations intermédiaires et
c'est à partir de ce moment là de plus
le confinement qui se fait dans à
l'intérieur de l'avion ne permet pas des
transports une reprise du moins des
transports envisageable tout de suite
alors le 11 mai ça veut aussi dire que
les ponts du mois de mai et bien voilà
ne pourront avoir lieu de toute façon
vous lisiez pas d'avion ça aussi c'était
une déception de votre part
c'est le côté des hôteliers canson c'est
une décision vous comprenez écoutez on
est obligé vous savez c'est le virus qui
pilote la machine
donc quand les scientifiques ont du mal
à appréhender si vous voulez le
phénomène les politiques encore moins
mais il est évident qu'on est obligé de
se résigner et puis attendre que le
disons du moins tout ce qui est
l'appareil de santé et là on doit quand
même remercier ceux qui aujourd'hui les
professionnels de santé qui oeuvre aux
côtés au quotidien d'une part et
deuxièmement ce régime parce qu'on n'a
pas le choix alors emmanuel macron qui a
effectivement indiqué hier soir que les
cafés restaurants et hôtels
n'ouvriraient pas pour l'instant sans
donner de date
on imagine que beaucoup de
téléspectateurs ont tendu l'oreille est
ce que vous vous avez des informations
complémentaires sur la date d'ouverture
de vos hôtels
notamment et des hôtels corse nous
pourrons envisager une ouverture que
quand on aura à la fois si vous voulez
le principe de la barrière et des
protections alors que ce soit le masque
que ça soit le test ou divers
aménagements qu'on pourra du moins
organisés il
il est impossible aujourd'hui de
rassembler des dizaines de personnes
dans un lieu commun est de pouvoir vivre
comme on lui vivait avant donc c'est il
es t il et il est inconcevable
et puis c'est pas souhaitable non plus
donc ça veut dire que tout le secteur va
devoir se réinventer en tout cas pour
eux notamment pour commencer cette
saison estivale parce qu'on se disait
qu'avec la fermeture de l'espace
schengen les français notamment
viendrait peut-être davantage encore se
resterait en tout cas en france ça me
dit qu'il va falloir réadapter peut-être
s'attendre à des vacances différentes
oui vous le savez on n'aura pas
d'étranger là l étranger paie stands
pour cent sur le tourisme en corse après
il ya un tourisme je dirais nationale et
là je pense qu'à la sortie de cette
crise peut être que les français ont
d'autres priorités d'une barre et auront
peut-être besoin de se ressourcer en
famille avec les amis alors ça va se
compliquer tout ça nous n'avons pas si
vous venez de clientèle domestique
puisqu'il ya que 33 cents mille a330
militants sur le sur l'île et ça ne
permettent pas si vous voulez d'autres
réguler l'économie touristique et elle
pèse très lourd comme vous l'avez dit
tout de suite au début de vos propos
donc ça aide pour nous il est
extrêmement difficile et je pense qu'il
faut sur ce savoir raison garder et en
même temps quand ce disque il faut se
préparer pour l'année à venir à
condition qu'on est je l'espère très
vite trouver un médicament dans
l'urgence et de vaccins dans un second
temps en tout cas beaucoup d'incertitude
on l'aura compris merci à jean pierre
pinelli vice président du cercle des
grandes maisons corses d'avoir été avec
nous pour vous exprimer donc sur cette
situation compliquée on l'aura compris
pour les restaurants les hôtels les
cafés français merci à vous et bouc
espère en tout cas que ce 15 mai signera
le redémarrage économique un redémarrage
peut-être relatif hier emmanuel macron a
déclaré déclaré qu'il faudrait rebâtir
notre économie et garder notre
indépendance financière la crise du
corps d'un virus à des conséquences
désastreuses sur l'économie les
prévisions sont alarmistes le miz
l'économie prévoit un recul de 8% du pib
en france en 2020 le déficit et la dette
vont se creuser beaucoup plus que prévu
c'est ce qu'a annoncé ce matin et bruno
le maire écoutez nous aurons une
prévision de croissance qui va être
fixée à -8% pour le projet de loi
rectificatif que je présenterai mercredi
en conseil des ministres il faut prendre
ces estimations avec prudence nous le
faisons car nous présentons un projet de
loi qui vise à abonder le fonds de
solidarité et à augmenter les mesures de
soutien aux entreprises
mais j'aimerais être certain que nous en
restions là les annonces du président de
la république vont aggraver les chiffres
des comptes publics
on va passer de moins 7,6 pour cent de
déficit à -9%
depuis la seconde guerre mondiale jamais
notre pays n'a connu cela on a corrigé
par deux fois un budget en trois
semaines et rajouter 110 milliards
d'euros pour soutenir l'économie les
salariés français la france met en place
ce qu'aucun autre pays ne met en place
dans ces conditions avec un chômage
partiel qui nous coûte 24 milliards
d'euros
et puis le fonds monétaire international
prévient que la croissance mondiale
devrait tomber cette année à 3% le à -3%
le fmi estime encore que la reprise
mondiale nécessitera plus de mesures de
relance coordonnés écouter sa machine
dans l'hypothèse où la pandémie et le
confinement nécessaire atteindrait un
pic au deuxième trimestre dans la
plupart des pays du monde
m6 reculerait au second semestre de
cette année inti prévoyons que la
croissance mondiale en 2020 va se
contracter de 3% tri possède lorsque la
reprise se produira et que nous aurons
dépassé la phase
pandémie il sera essentiel pour les
économies avancées d'entreprendre une
relance budgétaire à grande échelle et
celle ci serait encore plus efficaces si
elles étaient coordonnées entre toutes
les économies avancées du monde mais
pour évoquer ses conséquences
économiques du grand confinement comme
l'appelle désormais le fmi nous sommes
en direct avec jean marc sylvestre
journalistes et de taurian east economic
sur rt france bonsoir pour marc silvert
merci d'être avec nous
les prévisions du fmi un récession
mondiale historique recul de 3% on l'a
vu rebond de 5,8 pour cent
toujours selon le fmi l'année prochaine
c'est quand même encourageant ou
l'économiste que vous êtes est très
inquiet l'économiste que je suis weeds
est inquiet et il est inquiet notre plan
des répercussions sociales parce que
derrière une crise économique et
financière il ya évidemment des
répercussions sociales parce qu'il ya
des normes mais je suis aussi inquiet
des répercussions de la crise sanitaire
tout ça n'est pas réglé mais c'est vrai
que en termes purement théorique
si l'on regarde ce qui s'est passé la
situation va être catastrophique
c'est grave mais l'appareil de
production ne sera pas détruit
donc on peut comme les organisations
internationales penser que parce que
l'appareil de production n'a pas été
détruit on assiste à un rebond
l'année suivante il va falloir passer
l'année et il va encore falloir gérer ce
déconfinement qu'yves état de
confinement général dont je pense que
c'est une crise qui est totalement
inédite
on n'a jamais eu ça dans l'histoire
qu'on remonte très loin dans l'histoire
il n'y a pas eu de crise qu'ils soient
mondiale et qui soit aussi profonde que
celle ci les grandes que les guerres les
deux guerres mondiales ont fait des
dégâts considérables mais pas en termes
papa au niveau purement économique comme
celle ci est pas au niveau mondial pas
dans tous les hémisphères s'étaient
concentrés à l'espace européen la crise
de 1929 n'a pas eu cette ampleur là la
crise de 2008 ben non plus et on a su
gérer le redressement ce petit épais et
très troublant dans cette affaire est
née et bruno le maire je le sens bien
c'est que on n'est pas sûr de la
visibilité en matière de déconfinement
mais pas seulement français
partout ailleurs on ne sait pas ce qui
peut se passer et tant que nous aurons
cette épée de damoclès sur la tête
c'est à dire la présence d'un virus dont
on ne connaît pas l'identité mais on ne
sait pas exactement par où il va sans
traitement sans vaccin est bien le
rapport de confiance des acteurs de
l'économie ne pourra pas être restaurée
et sans confiance et bien vous n'avez
pas d'activité si le cours sauf si le
déconfinement dure encore quelques mois
ça va pouvoir être effectivement de
rappeler si on s'en tient à la fin mai
ou avant l'été voit dans la plupart des
pays développés
c'est vrai qu'on peut espérer l'année
prochaine mais l'année prochaine
mais entre temps on aura quand même de
sacrés facture à régler alors
effectivement jean marc sylvestre vous
ai dit ok des scénarios le fmi lui aussi
on évoque un trois alternatives une
pandémie non prises non maîtrisée à la
fin du mois de juin une seconde épidémie
survenue en 2021 mais plus légère une
troisième c'est la combinaison des
mauvaises nouvelles un prolongement de
la paralysie et du confinement au second
semestre suivie d'une seconde et puis
les miens survenant en 2021
voilà je vous demande pas de le lire
dans la boule de cristal mais vous
quelle est la liste que vous aux
privilégiés jean marc sylvestre
je pense que je pense que la piste puis
je voudrais privilégiées on peut on peut
évidemment imaginer tous et le fmi à un
scénario qui est un scénario de la fin
du monde donc on peut aussi privilégier
un scénario fondé sur les scientifiques
savoir que tous les laboratoires
aujourd'hui on retrouve sur le pied de
guerre
ils travaillent ils travaillent à des
traitements on en sait quelque chose
avec des débats qui sont parfois agités
dans la communauté scientifique mais ces
débats existent et ils sont ils sont de
bonne de bonne tenue
et puis la découverte d'un vaccin
on va forcément avoir des solutions
médicales sanitaire vers l'avant la fin
de cette année d'abord les tests ensuite
des traitements une fois qu'on aura les
tests on saura qui est malade et ceux
qui ne sont pas on sera ceux qui sont
porteurs d'anticorps et ceux qui ne sont
pas porteurs d'anticorps vous rendez
compte on aura fait un toit un chemin
énorme pour pour restaurer cette
confiance
et puis normalement
avax à l'institut pasteur nous laisse
penser qu'on aura un cadeau de noël ce
sera le parrain candidat russe je vois
ce confiance dans l'intelligence des
scientifiques parce que c'est vraiment
sur eux qu'il faut se fonder premier
point deuxième point il ya une réaction
naturelle des agents économiques pour
pouvoir se redresser
on a besoin de travailler on a besoin de
financer ce progrès on a besoin de
consommer il ya quand même un certain
nombre de lieux en chine où on
s'aperçoit la consommation a repris qu à
quelques industriels qu'ils nous le
disent et que c'est que c'est pas c'est
pas c'est pas complètement étouffé même
s'il ya encore des risques
faut il va falloir faire attention soit
la période la plus difficile qui va être
qu'il va venir si la période qui guide
d'aidé six mois prochain le
déconfinement justement jean marc
sylvestre donnez-moi le déconfinement
vous en parliez tout à l'heure on a vu
que certains pays favorisés plus que
d'autres peut-être l'économie donald
trump est très bien puisqu'il pousse
pour des confiné dès le 1er mai la suède
ou en europe a fait ce choix dès le
départ
est ce qu'il ne faudrait pas finalement
une solution uniforme pour tous les les
pays du mouron qu'on aille dans le même
sens non je pense pas je pense pas
anormale et illégitime que chaque pays
en fonction de sa culture
en fonction de ces structures politiques
sont de ses habitudes son éducation
aussi son niveau de développement
puissent développer son propre modèle
mais je dois dire que le pur le le job
et politique aujourd'hui et d'
absolument épouvantable parce que ils
doivent en permanence gérer deux
objectifs qui sont un peu contradictoire
le premier objectif c'est d'assurer la
sécurité sanitaire et la sécurité
sanitaire nous demandent de s'immoler du
quelque part d'étouffer un peu
l'activité humaine il faut rester chez
soi faux seins et puis le deuxième
objectif c'est de maintenir en activité
les mécanismes de production on voit
bien que c'est contradictoire et on voit
bien que même dans les mesures qu'a
donnée macro il est partagé
c'est un compromis entre la nécessité de
garantir la sécurité sanitaire et aussi
l'obligation qu'il a de ne pas tuer la
machine économique par un confinement
trop entre prononcer on voit bien par
exemple sur l'école on allait les restes
orateur ont le droit vous les entendiez
tout à l'heure de se demander pourquoi
on va autoriser les enfants à retourner
à l'école alors qu on n'autorisera pas
les clients à venir au restaurant
bon il est bien c'est un problème
d'économie qui qui qui viendra bon ça
c'est ça c'est ça c'est la la la la la
page la part de déco fil d'une boule de
confinement va être compliqué elle va
compliquer parce que le monde d'après
sera pas forcément le même que celui
d'avant même si je n'ai pas changé bien
justement jean marc sylvestre le monde
d'après ça sera ma dernière question
emmanuel macron qui atteignent
refondation est il un pas changé son
discours emmanuel macron il parle
d'indépendance financière notamment dans
les milieux industriels technologiques
sanitaires mais aussi agricole ça ne
vous a pas échappé c'est un vrai
changement de stratégie pour le
président thein c'est un bon c'est pas
forcément un vrai changement de
stratégie pour ma part c'est un c'est un
changement de discours d'analysé de
présentation il change sa pédagogie mais
il tient compte des faits ça bragg matic
il sait très bien que la digitalisation
va s'accélérer cette crise du virus du
coronavirus et bien fait un boulevard
pour toute la digitalisation on le voit
bien le télétravail
et puis les lalala l'utilisation des
progrès technologiques et cédera donc
c'est absolument indispensable la
deuxième chose c'est que c'est vrai on
va sans doute relooke alizés un certain
nombre d'activités
d'une part pour tenir compte des
contraintes qui peuvent exister en
matière justement de risque sanitaire
mais également d' indépendance en
matière de fourniture de essentiel d'un
certain nombre de choses et puis je
crois que la troisième chose mais ça ça
va être très important c'est qu'il va
faire qu'on s'organise nous mêmes
regardez je reviens sur vos
restaurateurs un restaurant qui oki qui
servait tous les soirs 80 couverts
il ne pourra plus servir 80 couverts
dans l'avenir c'est à dire dans l'année
qui vient ou peut-être dans les deux ans
il faudrait qu'ils organisent de la
distanciation sociale la distanciation
social c'est quoi eh bien il passera de
80 à 40 couverts alors il va falloir
quand même qu'ils s'organisent son
modèle économique est totalement
différent donc ça va quand même demandé
un énorme changement il y compris
d'ailleurs dans les méthodes de
gouvernement et j'ai trouvé que
sinon macron avec cette honnêteté non il
faudra que tout le monde change
y compris moi même merci jean marc
sylvestre d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france
confiné vous aussi merci à vous et de
son côté le président du medef
rétropédale il avait déclaré ce week-end
qu'il faudra bien se poser ton ou tard
la question du temps de travail des
jours fériés et des congés payés pour
accompagner la reprise économique
des propos qui ont suscité l'hostilité
des syndicats geoffroy roux de bézieux
jugent aujourd'hui que le débat sur la
question et clôt une augmentation du
temps de travail ne peut se faire que
dans le dialogue social avec les
syndicats par entreprise j'ai eu leur
réponse donc le débat est clos d'une
certaine manière puisqu'ils ont tous
répondu plus ou moins fortement qu'il
n'en était pas question
hier emmanuel macron admis des ratés et
des files gouvernementale depuis le
début de l'épidémie l'exécutif visé
justement par 28 plaintes pour sa
gestion de la crise sanitaire des
requêtes déposées à la cour de justice
de la république plusieurs ministres
dont edouard philippe et olivier ferrand
sont dans le viseur et précision en
images
[Musique]
et à lille à plusieurs étudiants en
médecine ou en école d'infirmiers sont
mobilisés pour aider les soignants elle
souhaite une réserve de 1500 volontaires
en fonction de leur année d'étude ils
peuvent se voir assigner plusieurs
tâches qui vont de la garde des enfants
du personnel soignant aux transports
hospitalier une épreuve de feu pour ces
futurs professionnels de la santé mais
aussi une façon d'épauler les soignants
aux premières lignes écouter leurs
témoignages
je suis les gens 5e and hospital à
spider universitaire je suis bientôt un
futur roxane de santé et ça me
paraissait évident d'apporter mon aide
ou à mes collègues peut-être futurs
collègues et au chu de lille je suis
content d'aider donc la fatigue ça ça
n'ont pas encore en jeu deux points
centre on a été formé à une ou deux
après midis et à partir de là on a selon
la tâche à laquelle ont été attribués on
a pu se mettre en route pour soi
produire du chat sous le reconditionner
et d'autres tâches encore mise en place
par faculté le chu de lille je suis
étudiant infirmier en deuxième année que
j'ai été réquisitionnés ici au service
des transports hospitalier du salon
c'est ma première semaine de mission au
service des transports
elle consiste à doc du coup à faire la
science clinique du patient à l'arrière
du véhicule et notamment donc du coup
des patients qui sont porteurs qui sont
en tout cas suspects ou avérés
comment on termine cette émission avec
une note plutôt légère ça fait du bien
un petit sourire le confinement et plus
généralement l'absence d'activité
humaine offre du répit aux animaux qui
eux sont plutôt contents ils
réinvestissent les milieux urbains
regarder
et
oui
oh
on vient vers nous au jeu plus bouger
plus et voilà penser
rafraîchissante c'est la fin de cette
émission un peu écourtée vous le savez
en raison du corona virus
rt s'adaptant comme tous les médias à
cette crise prochain point complet sur
l'actualité ce sera demain matin 8h
heure française
excellente fin de soirée à tous et bon
courage
[Musique]
360 millions d'euros vont être affectés
à la lutte contre les violences mais
finalement ce n'est pas plus que l'an
dernier
au niveau des mesures ou nous annonce
beaucoup de choses qui existent déjà qui
ne fonctionne pas pour preuve 138
victimes
le gouvernement ne nous entend pas le
gouvernement ne nous voit pas dans notre
association en trois mesures qu'on
demande au gouvernement
c'est un les priver de liberté donc avec
le bracelet anti rapprochement de les
toucher au porte-monnaie les foyers ça
va être à leur charge et 3 les priver de
leurs droits parentaux vous allez
continuer à vous bas